I am not a patient person by my
character I constantly want things to
happen faster I constantly compare my
progress to where I think I should be
based on an arbitrary thing which will
always be 25% further than wherever I am
right now if you say hey be patient
that's not helpful for someone cuz it
means nothing but when I Define patience
not as how I felt by simply what you do
in the meantime like right now you and I
are being patient for the stock market
Investments that you've made for some
deals that you have in the pipeline that
you're not pushing but you think they
might come to fruition for a split test
that you're running on one of your
websites but like you're not really
being patient you're just keeping busy
between now and then it's just figuring
out what to do in the meantime